[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es Churros Ringe.
Churros habe ich schon mal gemacht auf meinem Kanal,
aber es ist gefühlt schon ein halbes Jahrhundert her,
obwohl ich erst 29 bin.
Das musste ich jetzt sagen.
Ja, Churros, das sind frittierte, normalerweise lange
Gebäckstücke,
die oft in Zimtzucker gewälzt werden
und die dann mit einer Schokosoße serviert werden.
So habe ich sie auch damals gemacht.
Heute möchte ich Churros Ringe machen
und zwei verschiedene Soßen dazu zubereiten
und zwar einmal eine Salted Caramel Sauce,
also eine salzige Karamellsoße,
– bleiben wir doch beim Deutschen –
und eine Schokoladen-Chili-Soße.
Ich mache heute helle und dunkle Ringe.
Und später gucken wir einfach, was uns besser schmeckt
oder ob beide gleichauf sind.
Ich werde jetzt zuerst mal beide Soßen herstellen.
Denn die Churros an sich sind wirklich superschnell gemacht.
Die bestehen aus einem Brandteig.
Und ich will die einfach später warm zu der Soße essen.
Also fange ich mal an mit der Karamellsoße.
Für die Karamellsoße brauche ich
200 Gramm Zucker,
40 Gramm Wasser,
80 Gramm Butter,
200 Gramm Sahne,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und einen halben Teelöffel Meersalz.
Ich gebe jetzt zuerst mal den Zucker in den Topf.
Da das Wasser dazu.
Okay, nehmt etwas mehr Wasser.
Doppelt so viel Wasser.
Es war ein bisschen wenig Wasser.
Ich habe nämlich nur grob geschätzt.
Okay, ein bisschen mehr Wasser,
damit einfach der Zucker schön bedeckt ist.
Und jetzt braucht ihr auch erst einmal gar keinen Löffel,
sondern
ich schalte jetzt den Herd auf hohe Stufe,
damit der Zucker aufkocht.
Der soll ja jetzt karamellisieren.
Jetzt am besten gar nicht rühren,
damit der Zucker nicht so kristallisiert.
Also wirklich nicht rühren.
Einfach nur aufkochen lassen.
Und, sobald es kocht, schalte ich den Herd,
also das Kochfeld,
auf etwa mittelhohe Hitze zurück,
damit es dann eben nicht so schnell verbrennt.
Also dann wirklich auf mittelhoher Hitze
etwa bernsteinfarben einkochen lassen.
Und ihr müsst wirklich jetzt auch die ganze Zeit dabeibleiben.
Denn das Karamell soll nicht verbrennen.
Sonst wird es nämlich bitter.
[Musik]
Mit ein bisschen mehr Wasser
dauert es natürlich etwas länger,
aber besser, als wenn der Zucker unten schon anbrennt.
Und jetzt könnt ihr
– schaut mal.
Ihr seht ja hier am Rand, dass da noch Zuckerkristalle sind.
Die könnt ihr mit so einer Bürste oder mit einem
Pinsel
– ein Pinsel ist es –
mit Wasser einfach so ein bisschen runterwaschen
hier am Rand.
Muss nicht, aber dann habt ihr am Ende
eben auch keine Zuckerkristalle mehr drin.
[Musik]
Super!
Jetzt geht es um Sekunden!
Jetzt ist die Farbe gut.
Also so ein bisschen Bernstein ist es schon,
ein bisschen dunkler als eben Karamellbonbons.
Denn jetzt kommt Butter und Sahne dazu.
Also jetzt vom Herd runterziehen.
Ich rühre jetzt zuerst die Butter ein.
Ganz vorsichtig sein!
Denn Karamell ist wirklich superheiß,
kann auch spritzen.
Aua, schon am Topf verbrannt.
Ich habe meinen Finger am Topf verbrannt!
Ei, ei, ei!
Mmh!
Oh, das riecht lecker!
Cool!
Sobald sich die Butter gelöst hat,
kommt die Sahne dazu.
Die Sahne ist übrigens ein bisschen lauwarm.
Weil ich habe Sahne nie auf Zimmertemperatur.
Das heißt, ich musste sie kurz erwärmen.
Und das ist auch ganz gut.
Die Butter am besten auch nicht kühlschrankkalt verwenden.
Jetzt die Sahne dazu gießen.
Schön rühren!
[Musik]
Und, wenn sich jetzt ein Klotz bildet,
ist das nicht schlimm.
Dann geht einfach noch mal ganz kurz auf den Herd.
Bei mir hat sich jetzt keiner gebildet.
Aber ich gehe trotzdem noch mal kurz auf den Herd
zum Erwärmen,
gebe dann noch Vanilleextrakt dazu
und, wenn ihr möchtet, wie gesagt, noch Meersalz.
Dann habt ihr eine salzige Karamellsoße.
>> MURAT: Wow!
>> SALLY: Hallo!
>> MURAT: Alles sauber.
Sauberer wird es nicht.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> DENNIS: Bin ich schon drin?
>> SALLY: Was macht ihr?
Ich habe damit nichts zu tun.
So.
Jetzt einmal kurz kochen lassen
und fertig.
Ich gebe jetzt hier noch Salz dazu
für ein Salzkaramell.
Und dann fülle ich es jetzt in ein Schraubglas
und lasse die Soße einfach abkühlen.
>> MURAT: Frau Antje bringt Käse aus Holland.
>> SALLY: Wer ist Frau Antje?
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Achtung, Achtung!
Murat und Dennis wollen bitte
vom Kinderland abgeholt werden.
Murat und Dennis bitte!
Die Eltern von Murat und Dennis
mögen sie bitte im Kinderland abholen!
Danke!
>> DENNIS: Nein, ich bleibe hier.
>> SALLY: Ich gehe nicht mit!
>> DENNIS: Ich gehe nicht wieder weg!
>> SALLY: Ich gehe nicht weg von hier!
>> MURAT: Das ist so cool, gell?
>> DENNIS: Du kannst machen, was du willst,
geändert wird hier gar nichts!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Geschmack braucht kein Koffein.
>> SALLY: Hast du dir jetzt ernsthaft
alle Werbesprüche gemerkt?
Mit dem Ball!
Och, Murat!
Okay.
Die Soße lasse ich jetzt abkühlen.
Und dann geht es direkt an die zweite Soße!
Yummy!
Und ich kümmere mich mal noch um die zwei Jungs hier.
Für die Schokosoße nehme ich
150 Gramm Sahne,
150 Gramm Milch,
200 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade.
und etwas Chili.
Jetzt gebt ihr einfach beide Flüssigkeiten in einen Topf
und lasst sie aufkochen.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr die Soße
auch gerne noch mit etwas Rum verfeinern,
also auch einfach hier dazu geben.
Und kurz aufkochen lassen.
Die Zartbitterschokolade,
da nehme ich einfach immer Herrenschokolade,
weil die einfach einen sechzigprozentigen Kakaoanteil hat.
Und die breche ich dann vorher einfach in Stücke.
Das passt sehr gut.
Also immer, wenn ich Zartbitterschokolade sage,
meine ich eigentlich Herrenschokolade.
Aber ihr könnt auch Zartbitter nehmen.
Die hat ein bisschen weniger Kakaoanteil.
Schmeckt halt so ein bisschen schokoladiger
schon sehr gut.
Ja.
Und, was ich immer mache, ist
Gläser noch mal auskratzen.
Guck, wie viel da noch drin war!
[Musik]
Und jetzt kocht die Milch und die Sahne.
Jetzt kochen die Milch und die Sahne.
Jetzt habe ich den Herd ausgemacht,
rühre die Schokolade ein.
Jetzt einfach ganz kurz warten
und dann durchrühren,
bis sie geschmolzen ist.
Und, wenn ihr möchtet, gebt ihr dann noch Chiliflocken dazu
oder etwas Rum.
Wenn ihr nicht möchtet, dann lasst ihr sie einfach so.
[Musik]
Die fülle ich jetzt auch ab
und lasse sie abkühlen
und kann in der Zwischenzeit schon mal
den hellen Brandteig machen für die Churros Ringe.
Für den Brandteig nehme ich
60 Gramm Butter,
250 Gramm Wasser,
200 Gramm Mehl,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und vier bis fünf Eier.
Ich mache hier jetzt die hellen Churros zuerst.
Jetzt gebe ich einfach das Wasser in den Topf.
Dann die Butter dazu.
Die Zubereitung ist aber gleich.
Und bei den dunklen Schoko-Churros,
da nehme ich einfach noch ein bisschen Kakao dazu,
also ein bisschen weniger Mehl und Kakaopulver dazu.
Die Zubereitung ist da aber gleich.
Das heißt, ihr lasst jetzt zuerst mal
das Wasser mit der Butter aufkochen.
Salz kann auch gerne schon dazu.
Und kurz so lange kochen, bis die Butter geschmolzen ist.
So.
Das kocht jetzt hier schon schön.
Die Butter ist aufgelöst.
Jetzt kommt das Mehl dazu in einem Schwung.
Und jetzt schön einen Teigkloß bilden.
[Musik]
Und jetzt einfach ein bisschen abbrennen,
also nicht anbrennen.
Das muss ich leider jedes Mal dazusagen.
Abbrennen,
bis sich unten am Boden ein Belag bildet.
Das dauert so etwa eine Minute.
Und dann hat der Teig wirklich auch die perfekte Konsistenz
und kann später die Gase, die im Backofen gebildet werden,
auch halten
– nicht im Backofen, in der Fritteuse.
Und dann geht der Teig eben dadurch auf.
Also da müsst ihr wirklich darauf achten,
das schön jetzt abbrennen.
Aber im Backofen wäre es das gleiche Prinzip.
[Musik]
So sieht der Teig jetzt aus
und am Topfboden, wie gesagt, der weiße Belag.
Ich nehme jetzt den Teig raus
und fülle den jetzt um in eine Schüssel.
Und den Topf lasst ihr jetzt einfach abkühlen.
Denn der Belag hier unten,
der löst sich von ganz alleine.
Josh, du weißt, unser Knusperbrot.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das ist dann unser Knusperbrot,
unser Frühstück heute.
Genau.
Und jetzt lasse ich den Teig einfach ganz kurz abkühlen.
Ich drücke den dann hier
einfach immer so ein bisschen an den Rand,
dass er flach ist.
So geht es nämlich schneller.
Und genau das Gleiche mache ich auch hier
mit dem dunklen Teig.
Da nehme ich jetzt einfach 40 Gramm weniger Mehl
und dafür 40 Gramm Kakao.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Teig abgekühlt.
Und ich verrühre das jetzt hier mit der Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könnt aber auch einfach mit dem Löffel weiter rühren.
Dauert nur ein bisschen länger.
Oder mit dem Handrührgerät mit dem Knethaken.
Und jetzt kommt hier ein Ei nach dem anderen dazu.
Ihr könnt es normalerweise auch hier aufschlagen
und reinplumpsen lassen.
Aber bei Eiern muss ich sagen,
die schlage ich gerne separat auf.
Dann sehe ich auch, ob eine Eierschale drin ist
oder ob mal ein schlechtes Ei dabei ist.
Daher lieber so.
Und jetzt das Ei dazu geben.
Beim ersten denkt man,
es verrührt sich nicht gut.
Aber habt da ein bisschen Geduld.
Und, wenn das komplett eingerührt ist,
kommt das nächste dazu.
Und je nach Größe der Eier sind es vier bis fünf.
Nicht zu viele nehmen!
Der Teig darf jetzt auch nicht zu flüssig sein
und nicht zu weich sein.
Brandteig ist eher ein bisschen fest,
aber glänzend.
Und natürlich kommt hier noch Vanille dazu.
Die kann ich gleich dazu geben.
So ist die Konsistenz perfekt!
Der Teig glänzt schön,
ist aber auch nicht flüssig,
noch schön fest.
Perfekt!
Und jetzt bereite ich noch den Schokoteig fertig zu.
Und dann ist beides bereit zum
Aufspritzen und Frittieren.
Und bei der Schokovariante
Tonka Wonka!
Tonkabohne,
die könnt ihr entweder dazu reiben
oder einfach meine Tonkapaste verwenden.
[Musik]
Okay.
Ich starte jetzt erst mal mit dem hellen Teig.
Der kommt jetzt hier in einen Spritzbeutel rein.
Da habe ich jetzt so eine mittelgroße, fein gezackte Spritztülle
und habe jetzt zwei Spritzbeutel.
Der eine, der ist schon benutzt.
Und dann nehme ich auch immer
ganz gerne zwei übereinander.
Die sind zwar stabil,
aber Brandteig ist wirklich
– da muss man sehr mit Druck arbeiten.
Und da nehme ich einfach zwei,
um sicherzustellen, dass wirklich nichts platzt.
Und die könnt ihr dann einfach auswaschen
und das nächste Mal wieder benutzen.
Hat man einfach so ein besseres Gefühl
dann in der Hand auch.
So.
Wenn ihr die Churros als lange Stränge macht,
könnt ihr sie jetzt im Prinzip
direkt dann gleich ins heiße Fett rein spritzen
und dann immer mit einer Schere abschneiden.
Ich mache jetzt aber Churros Ringe.
Also muss ich die jetzt vorher aufspritzen
und habe jetzt hier mein Backpapier.
Das wird gleich zugeschnitten.
Aber ich mache jetzt erst mal alle Ringe,
damit ich das Backpapier nicht halten muss.
Und jetzt hier oben
– also beim Spritzbeutel ist es wirklich wichtig:
Oben zudrehen.
Die Hand übt den Druck aus
und die Hand führt,
also die Hand hier vorne.
Ob ihr jetzt Links- oder Rechtshänder seid, ist egal.
Hauptsache, die Hand hier oben
hält einfach den Spritzbeutel fest und drückt
und die Hand unten führt.
Und jetzt einfach kleine Ringe aufspritzen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt schneide ich das Backpapier einfach auseinander.
Ich habe jetzt auch noch nicht den ganzen Teig gemacht.
Den mache ich jetzt gleich.
Aber ich möchte jetzt nicht
die ganze Backpapierrolle verschwenden.
Daher benutze ich jetzt hier das Backpapier,
frittiere schon mal,
nehme das Papier raus
und benutze das Backpapier dann einfach weiter.
Dann braucht ihr nicht so viele zuschneiden.
[Musik]
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Frittenbude!
Jetzt wird frittiert!
Ihr könnt entweder eine Fritteuse nehmen
oder einfach im Topf frittieren.
Ich frittiere jetzt hier im Topf,
habe bereits Sonnenblumenöl
– oder Frittierfett könnt ihr auch nehmen –
in einem Topf erwärmt auf 170°C.
Wenn ihr euch nicht ganz sicher seid mit der Temperatur,
nehmt lieber eine Fritteuse
oder schaltet den Herd auf mittelhohe Stufe.
Ich habe es hier jetzt ganz einfach gemacht.
Ich habe nämlich einfach PerfectCook Sensor dran
und kann hier genau sehen: 170°C.
Und jetzt hält das Kochfeld auch wirklich
die Temperatur die ganze Zeit.
Denn, wenn jetzt was Kaltes reinkommt,
also so ein Ring,
dann heizt er wieder hoch
und hält einfach die Temperatur konstant.
Jetzt wird das hier schön reingelegt ganz vorsichtig.
Und mit einem Holzstäbchen
könnt ihr auch das Frittierfett testen
Ich ziehe es jetzt auch gleich ab,
kann es weiter benutzen.
Und dann wird es hier jetzt von beiden Seiten frittiert
und ausgebacken.
Und beim Frittieren immer darauf achten:
Nicht zu viele Ringe auf einmal hineingeben,
damit das Fett nicht zu schnell abkühlt
Sonst kann es nämlich auch schäumen.
Also das ist echt auch gefährlich!
Das ist, wie wenn man in einen Liter Frittierfett
so drei Kilo Tiefkühlpommes gibt.
Das geht auch nicht.
Und dann ausbacken und rausnehmen.
Und danach wälze ich sie direkt in Zimtzucker.
[Musik]
Hier kann ich jetzt schon mal Zimtzucker machen,
also einfach weißen Zucker
mit Zimt vermischen.
Und ich mache das jetzt hier in so einer Schale.
Mmh!
Das riecht lecker!
Und, wenn die Churros Ringe fertig sind,
– ja, sieht fertig aus –
nehme ich sie kurz raus und lasse sie hier abtropfen.
Und dann kommen sie aber noch ganz warm
hier in den Zimtzucker,
werden darin gewälzt
und sind dann erst mal fertig.
[Musik]
Ja.
Lecker!
[Musik]
Die Churros Ringe werden übrigens am allerallerschönsten,
wenn ihr sie ins heiße Fett gebt.
Und jetzt sind sie ja mit der Unterseite nach unten.
Ich drehe es jetzt einmal um,
damit erst die Unterseite gebacken wird
und dann nach dem Umdrehen die Oberseite.
Ja, so gefallen sie mir optisch am besten.
Und nicht zu früh rausnehmen!
Ich habe die ersten echt zu früh rausgenommen.
Die sind wieder zusammengematscht,
weil ich unbedingt in Zimtzucker wälzen wollte.
Aber die nächsten, die sind perfekt!
Die sind perfekt durchgebacken.
So kann es weitergehen.
[Musik]
Die Churros sind jetzt fertig!
Die beiden Soßen auch.
Jetzt kann probiert werden!
>> MURAT: So schnell ist keiner irgendwo,
Speedy-bi, Speedy-bo,
die schnellste Maus von Mexiko!
Speedy-bi, Speedy-bi, Speedy-bo!
So.
>> SALLY: Ich finde das so schön immer,
wenn du dich als Mexikaner verkleidest.
>> MURAT: Ich finde das so was von...
Darf ich gar nicht sagen.
Eigentlich war ich gerade im Wald
– nicht im Wald, im Garten.
Und dann haben die gesagt,
der Dennis,
ich soll das anziehen, weil du Churros machst
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: aus Mexiko.
>> SALLY: Nein, Churros ist ein spanisches Gebäck.
Von der Iberischen Halbinsel.
Und das ist Spanien, Portugal.
>> MURAT: Wieso hat er dann gesagt, das ist mexikanisch?
>> SALLY: Weil es cool aussieht?
>> MURAT: Okay.
Ich möchte mich hiermit bei allen Mexikanern entschuldigen.
Ich möchte niemanden verunglimpfen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Die haben aber die gleiche Sprache.
>> MURAT: Ja. Also es gibt kein Mexikanisch.
Mexikanisch ist Spanisch,
so wie Amerikanisch auch Englisch ist.
So.
Wusstet ihr nicht?
Ich sage es euch.
Soll ich  jetzt probieren?
Warum muss ich...
>> SALLY: Ich habe noch eine schlechte Nachricht für dich.
>> MURAT: Ja. Die wäre?
>> SALLY: Fasching ist schon lange vorbei,
Karneval auch.
Du kannst es nicht mehr abgeben,
weil zwei Wochen Rückgabe ist schon vorbei.
>> MURAT: Wir lassen immer alles dran.
>> SALLY: Jetzt kannst du das Schild wirklich mal abmachen.
>> MURAT: Lass es dran!
Dann kann ich es noch zurückschicken.
So.
>> SALLY: De-de-d-d-d-d-de...
Ach, nee, das ist griechisch.
>> MURAT: Liebe Grüße an Dennis,
wenn du das siehst,
das zahle ich dir heim!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also wir haben zum einen
Schoko-Tonka-Churros
und Salted Caramel
und helle Vanille-Churros
und Vanille...
– Schoko-Chili.
>> MURAT: ¡Ándale!
So.
Darf ich das mal probieren jetzt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ich finde das ganz ehrlich...
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das mache.
>> SALLY: Ich finde die auch ohne Dip genial!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Ich würde sie ohne Dip essen,
weil die sonst zu süß sind.
>> SALLY: Gar nicht!
>> MURAT: Hm.
Hm.
>> SALLY: Der getürkte Mexikaner,
der weiß nicht, was gut ist.
>> MURAT: So.
Aber
süß.
Ehrlich!
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> MURAT: Doch!
Ich finde es süß.
>> SALLY: Gar nicht!
Ich finde dich süß.
>> MURAT: Danke.
Ich gucke gerade in die Kamera.
Das sieht so bescheuert aus.
Wenn ich das esse, dann wackelt das ganze Gesicht.
Macht es gut!
Tschüss!
Viel Spaß mit den Churros, mit Tonka Wonka
und mit
>> SALLY: Zimt.
>> MURAT: Zimt
und mit zu viel Chili in Schokolade!
>> SALLY: Die brennt dreimal!
>> MURAT: Aber
lecker!
Auch ganz wichtig noch:
– fragen die meisten Leute –
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Immer frisch essen, gell?
Schmeckt am besten, muss man ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Frittiertes Gebäck immer frisch.
>> MURAT: Frittiertes immer frisch essen!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Denn am nächsten Tag ist es
nicht mehr frittiert.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Nicht mehr frisch.
>> MURAT: Und nicht frisch.
Tschüss!
Nehme ich mit an meine mexikanischen Freunde,
an den
Dennis.
So, Dennis.
>> SALLY: Kannst du...
Schatz,
kannst du jetzt bitte
das griechische Kostüm für mich anziehen?
>> MURAT: Ich ziehe kein griechisches Kostüm an.
Mit ganzer Sicherheit nicht.
Wieso muss ich...
>> SALLY: Oder so wie die alten Römer, nur so ein Blatt.
>> MURAT: Nein, mache ich auch nicht.
Mein Gott!
Ich gehe.
Tschüss!
Netflix, Markus, vier mit Murat.
>> SALLY: Der ist ganz rot geworden!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Okay.
Och Gott!
Mein Gott!
[Musik]